just when you didn't think it could get
any better huh hi I'm such a big fan of
IMAX in the platform of IMAX technology
of IMAX especially when movies are
created in a way with IMAX in mind
you feel like you're in the movie no
it's a monstrous screen the detail is
incredible the shot designed action
sequences it's a truly heightened
experience that's what this is you have
fast cars massive epic in scale stunt
sequences some of those set pieces I
mean that the plane drop is spectacular
the scene of course where they're
driving the car from the penthouse suite
through three different skyscrapers
I think that's going to be very
interesting to see because of the
adrenaline rush you can feel the rumble
in the chest you can feel the woofers
you can feel the wind audio wise their
epic and they boom they shake you to get
the full surround sound you get the
wheel appeal the message crane it's like
you're actually there in person the
experience is second to none I hope
Jason Statham I lift him in the air I
deliver a rock bottom for the first time
seen ever in I met
worth the price of admission
you